What’s your favorite word?
Think about it for a moment.
Think real hard.
Write it down in the comments, post it for
everyone else to see.
How many letters does it have?
How many syllables?
Say it aloud.
How does it sound?
How does it feel on your tongue?
Really, really think about it.
Now, make sure you keep that word in mind,
it’s important, and we’ll come back to
it later.
For now, it’s time to talk about SCP-3449.
Look, there’s really not anything special
about this one.
It wasn’t even important enough to be mentioned
with the other infohazards.
It’s no evil talking toaster, that’s for
sure.
SCP-3449 appears to be just a standard spiral
notbook - notbook?
It’s supposed to be notebook, right?
Anyway, it’s a standard spiral notebook
with a dark blue cover.
It’s Safe-Class, and it’s stored in a
standred - ahem… a standard containment
locker in Site-19.
There aren’t any other containment requires,
but testing is currently underway to determind
- I think that’s meant to be determine - long-term
containment requirements.
Ugh, this is a mess.
Anyway, this item and its anomalous power
is actually considered so inconsequential
that researchers have explored the possibility
of putting it on the anomalous items log,
a place where items too useless to warrant
a full file end uzp.
Jeez, how did you misspell “up” that badly?
It’s two letters, well it’s supposed to
be two letters.
How did you work a Z into that, they aren
’t even close to each other on the keyboard!
Man…
Anyway, the notebook contains mostly blank
pages.
Some are torn, and only six contain actual
writing, but due to the formatting of the
writting, the text - consisting mainly of
diary entries - is almost unreadable.
This is due to syntactical errors, random
capitalization, and rampant impsmellings.
Great.
You misspelled misspellings.
How cute.
Apparently, all attempts to correct these
misspellings fail, or even lead to additional
misspellings.
This anomalous affect extends to anyone attempting
to right… yep, that was spelled r-i-g-h-t
- anyone attempting to write about SCP-3449,
including the script for this video apparently.
There are no further notable amonolous properties.
Tests are ongoing, those with any inquiries
about testing SCP-3449 should contact Lead
Researcher Niklo Gerdinel.
The notbok - which was misspelled even worse
that time… impressive - was first recovered
by MTF Epislon Six, also known as the Village
Idiots, after a series of infohazardous and
cognitohazardous phenomena were discovered
in the Pittsburgh Metrode Area.
The source seemed to be a storage unit filled
with anomalous items, and SCP-3449 was amogus
- I think that’s meant to be among - them.
The storage unit was registered to a man by
the name of Edward Selsburgh, currently designated
as Porpoise of Interest 4335.
Phew.
That’s the end of that.
Thanks for watching the video, folks, now
go check out- Oh, wait, there’s more.
Apparently that version of the file was an
older one, let’s check the next one and
see if that’s any more useful…Oh.
Oh my.
It appears that the updates here are actually
quite extensive.
Okay, let’s give this another try.
SCP-3449 is a Euclid-Class SPC kept in the
humanid containment sells of Site-19.
Items affected by it are kept in standard
stroage lockers for Safe-Class anomalous objects
at the same site.
The primary reason for this shift is that
SCP-3449 has changed its object of designation:
It is no longer the spiral notebook, it is
now a 34-year-old Caucasian man known as Edward
Selsburgh, formerly known as Person of Interest
4335.
He is believed to be the creator of the notbok,
as well as the other obects found inside the
storage looker in Pittsburgh.
Fundation personnel are now trying to locate
and contain any other objects created by Mr.
Selsburgh, though success has been lomited
on this front.
SCP-3449’s analogous abilities manifest
onto both Edward himself, and all the objects
created by him.
Wirting about him or any of these objects
will result in sytanictal errors, arbitrary
capitalizatoon, and rampart impsmellings.
Attempts to revise or correct the writing
will either fail to remove the errors, or
create new errors.
It appears that the anomalominous effects
of SCP-3449 proper are more severe than that
of the ones caused by his anomalous objects.
MTF Epsilon-6, also known as the Village Idyots,
apprehanded SCP-3449 in his apartment just
outside of Prittsburgh.
He appeared to be in an advanced state of
disorontation and dehydration.
Records collected by the Mubile Task Force
found that Mr. Selburgh had not left his apratment
in over ten days, which would account for
his dire health conditions.
Selsburgh did not communicate with mambas
of the Task Force, but did not resest arrest
and subsequent containment either.
Okay, okay, these spellings are rough, but
I’m going to try to power through.
We’re almost there.
The following is the full lug of items obtained
from SCP-3449’S storage locar that also
exhibit his anomalous effects.
The Notebook - As already disgust, the pages
are either blank, torn, or illegible.
Selsburgh’s computer - Files saved on the
devise include spreadsheets detailing personal
finances, ideas for products, and an unfinished
horror novel that is almost unraidable due
to the pore quality of its writing.
Grocery List - Had only two written items:
“buter” was spelled with only one “t”,
and “medication” which was spelled “medicashun”.
A Planner - Last entry was dated two weeks
before containment, and believed to contain
reminders to perform various chores, however
a mixture of poor handwriting and word choice
allows for other interpretations.
And finally, Mr. Selsburgh’s cell phone.
Foundation researchers were able to collect
the call logs in hopes of further tracking
Selsburgh’s pre-containment activities.
The last three calls, which were all made
on the same day two weeks before continment,
dialed different numbers, only one of which
was in use.
The Foundation made contact with the receiverer
of said call, who head no knowledge of SCP-3449,
and claimed that they did not answer the call.
Lead Researcher Niklo Gerdinel conduced the
first innerview with SCP-3449 shortly after
his capture.
When he entered the interview chambie, he
found that SCP-3449 was just sitting in the
corner with his had in his hands, rocking
back and furth in what appeared to be apparent
distress.
He then begun looking don into his lap and
twiddling his thumbs like a child.
Niklo engaged him in a calm and polite tone,
addressing him as SCP-3449.
The anomly made eye contact with Dr. Gerdinel,
but didn respond, and instead continued starring
at him.
As Gerdinal axed further questoons, Selsburgh
simply didn’t answer, or would, at the very
most, acknowledge the questions with simple
gestures.
Gerdinal asked whether Selsburgh was making
products for his business, to which he smiled
and shuk his head.
Gerdinel than asked Selsburgh whether he could
speak or not, or if it was merely a choose
on his part.
Unsurprisingly, Selsburgh offer no explanation,
and the interview cime to a close shortly
afterwards.
Tests are steell ongoing
to find out if Selsburgh’s
inability to spake or commonicate come as
a result of his anomalous traits, or if this
is simply a result of aphonia - a uncommon
but non-anomalous condition that renders its
victims unable to spike.
Tests have confirmed that Selsburgh does have
all the oregons required for vocalisation,
but sappears to not use them.
Further tests are requirep.
Alright, there we have it!
That was a complete nightmare to read thanks
to SCP-3449’s anomalous effects, but at
least it’s over now.
Go check out- Wait...There’s more?
Another update to the file?
Sigh…
Okay.
Let’s take a look…
Oh...I see...This is a lot more dangerous
than I thought.
I suppose I better read on…
SCP-3449 hays ben upgraded to Keter-Class
anomol.
SCP-3449-A - the new designation for Edward
Selsbegher - is to be kept in high-security
hazmart conmaintent in Site-19.
The inanimate anomalous possessions of Edward
Selsburgh are to be keept in standard object
containment.
Any reports written on SCP-3449 must be wrotten
by pople who have been exposed to it for less
than seven days, in order to keep the files
raidable.
To prevent this infectious infohezmard from
spread further, the number of people allowed
to interact with this anomaly is kept relatively
small, and consists of those that have already
been explosed at some point or another.
This includes: O5-8, MTF Epsilon-6, Dr. Teller’s
research team, some additional personnel selected
for XPC-3449 research, and porsonneil chosen
to update SCP-3449 documentation.
While Edward Selsbergh and his presonal effects
are crunntly locked up, SCP-3449 is not currently
considered contained.
Research into the sprad of SCP-3449’s effects,
the vectors for transmission, and any potential
remcredies for its degenerative effects are
now tope priority for all inloved - before
this hole ting gets out of hand.
Further research has taught the Foundation
that not only are Selsburgh and his items
powerful infohazards, their anemlous effects
appear to be able to infect these who experience
them permanently.
Initially, it will appraer that writing quamity
only degrades when the subject is actually
writing about SCP-3449 itself, but over time,
they’ll come to the frightening relzation
that it actual affects their writhing as a
whole.
The effect also progresses in its semerity
over time, eventually rendering the victim’s
ability to write legible sentences completely
desployed.
The initial anomalous effects of SCP-3449
were discrover when MTF Epsilon-6 write their
field report on the mater, and found it littered
with syntlacticol errer, random capitalizato,
and rampant impillings.
Similar errors appearing in the initial faile
about SCP-3449 ownly served to reaffirm this
observation.
However, researcher only began to notice true
extent of SCP-3449’s effects when the Village
Idiots’ field reports concerning other solomonies
came in with equally atrocious writing.
Attempts to correct this writing simply led
to more mastakes, and frustration on part
of team.
Soon after, a restircher name Dr. Teller - who’d
since tarken ovor the SCP-3449 case - and
his team found that they were experience stimilar
issues.
They just couldn’t make the blurds happen,
no matter how hard they constentrated.
They forgot spellings, they couldn’t make
hand move in the manner they waited it to
in order to form the words.
Even the most intelligent and articulate members
of the team came across as extremely young
chrildren on page.
But didn’t stop there.
Wasn’t long before researchers who’d never
worked on the SCP-3449 case staring to exhobit
these same suspicious errors in own writing.
The Foundation didn’t know how, but the
silck-ness was starting to spread, with people’s
abilities to write degrading across the entire
Floundation.
That’s when a Foundation webtrawler pick
up seemthing even more dousturbing: Global
literacy seemed to be taking a dive.
The telltale styntacal error, random tcapization,
and rampant llingsmellings ticking up everywhere,
and for everyone.
And the end of writing would be one thing,
but SCP-3449 doesn’t stop there - No, that’s
just the breginning.
Morse code go next, then pictograms.
Not long ‘fore sign language become hopeless
scrambled.
C-co-communication b-breaks down.
Little by lrittle.
People can’t draw aymore.
They c-can’t move hands right.
It all goes.
Calls.
Codes.
Last go is voice.
Talking gets hard.
Remember favrourite word?
Think about it.
Say it loud.
When SCP-3449 done, when everyone infected,
you’ll never say it gain.
Nobody will ever say anything again.
I...I…
Now go check out “Minecraft World Destroyer
SCP-4335 - A Welt In The Crucible” and “SCP-055
- Anti Meme / Unknown” for more mind-bending
anomalies from the SCP Foundation!